major development the quest for the
coronavirus vaccine as pfizer announces
their covet 19 vaccine more than 90
percent effective it's stunning news
but new york governor andrew cuomo says
there's a downside
the bad news is that it's about two
months before
joe biden takes over and that means this
administration is going to be
implementing a vaccine
plan the vaccine plan is very important
and it's probably the most ambitious
undertaking
undertaking since covert began the trump
administration is rolling out the
vaccination plan and i believe it's
flawed
here now fox news medical contributor
author of this great book covent
the politics of fear and the power of
science dr mark
siegel uh dr siegel first off andrew
cuomo doesn't like the military
implementing a plan that's ready to go
and it can be monitored in the smallest
hospital in the biggest city
what's not good about this plan that was
featured on 60 minutes
48 hours ago brian you just took the
words out of my mouth we've never had it
before where the dod the department of
defense
which knows the word deployment don't
they partners with the cdc and mckesson
a company that has
already sent vaccines around the country
multiple times
the plan is in place and has never been
done this way before they're already
geared up
to already send out 50 to 100 million
doses
and you know governor cuomo is talking
about underserved areas but the plan
includes temporary clinics being built
in underserved areas
on indian reservations in poor
neighborhoods in order to get the
vaccine to people who need it the most
health care workers will get it the
elderly will get it the poor minorities
will get it
all he's doing is shaking confidence in
a vaccine that we have very
exciting news about and our big mess our
big problem is going to be vaccine
compliance
how disturbing is that for him to be
shaking the
confidence in this vaccine at exactly
the wrong time and we think they could
be ready they want to get the shot going
their words
at the end of this month but they need
two shots i understand it then all of a
sudden later in the day
i read about moderna said excuse me i
got one too
what should we know about that well
that's a very similar technology and
that's been under the auspices of the
nih they're looking very cl
closely at the moderna vaccine both of
these vaccines use genetic material to
signal your cells brian
to make the spike protein from the virus
and guess what we're now seeing a robust
immune response
we saw over 90 percent of people who got
sick with covet were in the placebo
group
so the vaccine is protective this has
never ever been done before at this rate
of speed
this is a historical day for science and
again the governor should be ashamed of
himself to be attacking the vaccine
while we're excited about getting it out
there and by the way just uh i'm going
to move over to biden's plan but eli
lilly to start shipping the coronavirus
antibody drug immediately
after getting emergency fda approval in
the second covit 19 breakthrough in 24
hours
amazing just a week from the election
okay i know it's a coincidence
let's talk about what the president of
president-elect
biden said yesterday he put out a plan
and here's the skeleton of it we're
going to restore the white house
national security council directorate
for health and security re-engaging
with the whl relaunching a pathogen
tracking system
calling all governors to enact mass
mandates and calling authorities to
reinforce
orders what's new about this
well brian we already have a mass
mandate in over 30 states and tennessee
studied a mass mandate recently
and found that when it's done in
conjunction and this is the key part
with distancing and no crowds it
actually decreases hospitalizations
we know that a mask helps but a mask is
not the big issue the big issue is
distancing
and not being in crowds so i was
disturbed to see the celebratory crowds
when when president-elect biden you know
was was out there after the election
there were celebratory crowds
huddling together how much virus was
spread then if they want to spend
send a message of compliance the message
should be don't gather to celebrate
celebrate the vaccine by the way don't
celebrate victories yeah and more
regulations
and more mandates brian are going to
lead to non-compliance
not more compliance and doctor right
before i came on i checked your book to
see if there was any exemption if notre
dame b
clemson can you celebrate and you did
not have an exemption so i'm sorry notre
dame
get tested now i understand it was a big
win but you can't
run on the field without masks dr siegel
congratulations on the first key
yes testing is key brian that's the
thing okay and they wanted
for notre dame right absolutely and they
got they said don't leave campus without
being tested
uh kova 19 right over your right
shoulder it's a great book it answers
all the questions
thanks dr siegel thank you brian